[Music]
over the past decade student loan debt
has skyrocketed in the u.s
by december 2020 43 million americans
owed the government a collective 1.6
trillion dollars
that's putting pressure on
president-elect joe biden
we know that in the 21st century 12
years of schooling is not enough
and that young people are getting
crushed by the burden of student debt
democrats want biden to issue an
executive order to forgive some loans if
a bill can't get through congress but
opponents say
that would unfairly assist high income
earners while increasing the existing
burden on taxpayers
what's happening is a lot of people are
not sending in payments to the education
department
about a third of the 1.6 trillion
dollars that's on the books currently is
not going to get repaid which basically
means taxpayers are
going to have to cover that somehow
so what will joe biden do first he wants
to bring back
a policy sought by congressional
democrats early in the pandemic
the legislation passed by the democratic
house calls for
immediate 10 000 forgiveness of student
loans
it should be done immediately from there
biden says he wants to start
by revamping the existing forgiveness
options offered by the federal
government
there are these programs in place called
income based repayment and the first of
these was actually
passed under the clinton administration
you know bill clinton actually liked the
idea of having
students actually pay a share of their
income each month rather than a fixed
dollar amount
one example of these programs is called
repay which stands for revised pay as
you earn
in repay plans anyone who's struggling
to pay their student loan
can set a new minimum payment that is 10
of their income over 25 000
if the borrower makes these payments on
time for 20 to 25 years
the government will forgive the
remaining balance of the loan now keep
in mind this is 10
of your discretionary income so for some
people it might not make sense if you're
making a lot of money
you know and um 10 actually might be
higher than what your standard repayment
is
so you kind of have to look at it and
see if it makes sense but anyone
can can do this um you're entitled to
enroll in this program and a lot of
people have enrollment in this program
has surged
but there's a catch the forgiven balance
of the loan is counted as income
on your taxes you know if you think
about it that tax bill can actually be
really high if you
if if it's let's say you owe a hundred
thousand dollars at the end of that
20-year program
well that's a hundred thousand dollars
of income and so that could be thousands
of dollars in
a tax bill that you face right then and
there at the end at the end of
your repayment plan biden's proposal
changes this program in a way that draws
less money from borrowers
the minimum payment rate for these plans
would be reduced from 10
to 5 percent of a borrower's income
after their first 25 thousand 000
earned and biden wants to make it so
that forgiven debt
won't be taxed as income biden also
wants to sweeten the terms of
forgiveness
for public sector workers like teachers
military personnel
and also employees of non-profits people
in these career fields already have
their debts forgiven tax-free
after 10 years of public service but
biden wants to relieve
some of their debts on a shorter
timeline biden has said
that the current program isn't working
as intended there is a program that
exists now under the law that forgives
student loans
for being able to engage in engaging in
public service
i'm going to institute that fundamental
change in that so it's able to be
available to everyone
that in fact is engaged it's not being
very well managed right now so i'm going
to do all of those things
some say that contractors are to blame
for the management issues
the contractors that the education
department
uses to deal with students who have
student loans
have gotten a lot of things wrong so
what you've seen is there have been a
lot of
instances of where people thought that
they were on track to get forgiveness
and then they learned that they're not
and they maybe have to start all over
so this program has turned out to be a
mess and he wants to fix that
members of both political parties think
that the federal student loan program
needs an update one of the big
differences right now is on the
democratic side they're saying
cancel student debt right now and then
we'll worry about reforming the program
republicans are saying
wait a minute the first thing we need to
do is fix this program
to solve the underlying problems in the
first place any student loan debt that's
forgiven
is covered by taxpayers mr biden says
he'll pay for expanded debt forgiveness
by reversing parts of the tax cuts of
2017.
for a lot of his plans he wants to you
know raise taxes on high earners on our
corporations corporate profits
so more broadly he's talked about doing
that
another issue is who exactly benefits
from expanded loan forgiveness programs
most student debt is actually held by
people who are in upper income
households
the brookings institution shows that uh
60 percent of student debt so more than
half of the 1.6 trillion on the books
is held by people who are making 74 000
a year or more but if debts are forgiven
the smaller payouts given to lower
income households are likely to have a
bigger impact on that household's
finances
in recent years roughly one in five
student loan borrowers
fell behind on their payments according
to the federal reserve
bank of new york that's a sign that many
remain at risk of default on their
student loan which could impact their
credit
or even lead to garnished wages if you
look at the number of people that have
defaulted on their loans
that's almost the same as the number of
people who lost their homes during the
housing crash
this was almost unheard of you know in
the early 2000s that there would be
someone calling for
canceling student debt so it shows just
how much of a
middle class anxiety this has become in
just the past 10 years
and biden hopes to relieve that anxiety
over the debts in his first term